and I think from for for young people
out there there's just this you know
lack of friendship and a lack of
togetherness and even if it's in school
that's fine but then you go home and you
go on your iPad and you're alone and you
don't know what kind of thoughts are
going through people's heads when
they're home alone in front of a screen
and I think it's incumbent on parents I
think it's incumbent on teachers I think
it's a comment on friends I think it's a
coming on family to just check in on
people that you think may have a problem
and even kids that you don't have a
problem and I think this is a this is an
American issue that we need to to tackle
foreign
[Music]